[Music]
you better stop being so damn selfish
and stop feeling sorry for yourself
you don't care about me you left me for
a better job
you totally left me for a better guy
because i wouldn't let me for what a mom
my dad let me forgive war
everybody leaves me
whether you only check out new shows
once they become popular tick-tock memes
or you still refer to them as my stories
everyone enjoys getting sucked in by a
gripping tv drama on today's rt
essentials we're looking back at the
most compelling tv series of all time
the shows you absolutely cannot stop
watching even though you gotta be up
early tomorrow and you're really gonna
feel it in the morning just one more
episode it's fine you'll have an extra
cup of coffee clive has the evening off
right cook
we got something we need you to sign
and just to enable your bad binching
habits further because that's what we do
here we have an announcement to make
about a special something we think
you'll love so the less you've been
enjoying on the show are typically based
on our editorial pieces you can find on
our website rottentomatoes.com but this
episode's list is based on a section of
our brand spanking new book for all you
television completists out there
introducing
rotten tomatoes the ultimate binge guide
with 296 must-see shows that change the
way we watch tv not only is it a
fascinating look into the evolution of
tv through engaging series write-ups
infographics and deep dive essays we see
it as a challenge a bingeable bucket
list of the shows you just have to see
before you die broken down into fun
sections like tony walt don and the
anti-heroes we loved and hated animation
that demands to be taken seriously
competitions and docu-series that
capture the zeitgeist and much more the
ultimate binge guide is available for
pre-order now and will be released in
november so make sure to grab one
because there really isn't any better
companion for the seasoned couch potato
and novice alike
except you know actual chips chips are
actually the best seasoned potatoes to
be eaten on a couch i hear the argument
from waffle fries i'm going with chips
okay we got the coffee i like iced tea
yeah we'll swap out iced tea got the
chips we got a final reminder that the
spoil alert is in effect for all the
shows going to be talking about and if
you're ready
let's get dramatic
desperate housewives normally there's
never anything newsworthy about my life
but that all changed last thursday
before creating desperate housewives
mark cherry was best known as a writer
producer for the still beloved sitcom
golden girls jerry started pitching a
concept for a darkly comic prime time
soap opera which he referred to as a
combination of knott's landing and
american beauty with a bit of twin peaks
thrown in
[Music]
no networks jumped on the project until
fox had a monster hit in 2003 with its
own primetime soap the oc prompting abc
executives lloyd braun the seinfeld no
that's a different lloyd braun and susan
lynn to take a chance on desperate
housewives around this time brawn and
lynn also took another chance on a big
risky project called loss then they got
fired by disney but nonetheless these
gambles both paid off desperate
housewives was an immediate hit for abc
the pilot roped in a then record 21.3
million viewers and the season one
finale became the show's most watched
episode of all time with nearly 30
million people viewing it terry
originally envisioned the show as a
30-minute comedy that would be more
satirical and lighter in tone but the
decision to span into a more severe
hour-long drama meant that it could go
to some darker places i remember you
getting drunk on tequila and coming into
my room and putting your hand over my
mouth and raping me to this day
desperate housewives remained one of the
most homicidal tv shows in history 52
characters were killed off over the
show's eight seasons including a number
of the prominent members of the ensemble
with all my neighbors surrounding me
i took my last breath
the good news
i died just like i lived
as the complete and utter center of
attention the set for the main street
where most of the characters live
wisteria lane was constructed on the
universal backlot in an area that's been
in regular use since the 1940s known as
colonial street you can actually drive
right past this if you go on the
universal studios backlot tour but
definitely look out for king kong
because dude's a menace i killed the son
of a hurt my wife if i have to go to
prison i will
[Music]
that's not gonna happen
friday night lights hey you gonna knock
them on and say don't stop driving keep
driving your legs keep moving yes sir
you want to come by tomorrow come out
practice with us
yes sir all right you beat my office at
seven o'clock not 701 7 o'clock sharp
we'll fit you up all right
all right then high school football
drama friday night lights started life
as a 1990 nonfiction book by author h.g
bissinger which inspired a 2004 movie
from director peter berg who it turns
out is actually the author's second
cousin boy everyone is someone's second
cousin the nepotism in this town you
think you're a champion because you wear
the panther uniform you're wrong
you think you're a champion because they
give you a piece of pie at the diner
you're wrong nbc had already tried to
mount a friday night light series in the
early 90s shortly after bissinger's book
was first published they couldn't
purchase the rights however because
they'd already been snatched up by the
planned film adaptation while prepping
the film berg spent some time with texas
high school football players and worked
some of their stories and experiences
into the series berg attended one 2003
game in which a young san antonio
football player david edwards was
paralyzed and this experience was a
major influence on him when conceiving
of the show give all of us gathered here
tonight the strength to remember that
life is so very fragile
we are all vulnerable
and we will all at some point in our
lives
fall berg also insisted that the show
actually be produced in texas which he
thought was essential for authenticity
the bulk of the series was filmed in the
towns of austin and pflugerville though
some key sequences were shot at
philadelphia's temple university which
stands in for the show's fictional
braymore college
[Music]
many of the crowd scenes feature real
locals being used as extras for
additional versamilitude the production
would stage large events like scene set
at football games in real time and the
crew would film the actor's documentary
style rather than repeatingly stopping
down and doing new setups to capture
everything from multiple angles
[Applause]
gossip girl tell me you love me
and everything we've done all the gossip
and the lies and the hurt
will remember something maybe it was
but it's not anymore you may be shocked
to hear that even after six seasons and
121 total episodes the cw's gossip girl
never won a single emmy it was however a
huge hit at the teen choice awards
taking home 18 total prizes over its run
and winning choice show drama each year
from its debut through 2011 which is
four straight wins which means you know
a lot of other shows got slimed if you
want my advice it's run lola run cause
you just let out the mother of all
secrets the show was based on a book by
cecile von ziegeeser that was originally
set up as a movie vehicle for lindsay
lohan written by gilmore girls
mastermind amy sherman palladino which i
for one would still like to see the cw
gossip girl pilot is actually a fairly
faithful adaptation of the book with
most of the characters based on von
zieger's original creations 10 bucks
whatever hair brain scheme your coconut
blows up in your face as per usual
lettering lounge is upstairs already
there sister penn badgley had first
turned down the role of brooklynite dan
humphrey he was feeling frustrated after
having worked on a number of pilots that
didn't get picked up after producers
looked elsewhere and couldn't find
anyone else they liked they offered him
the part a second time by this point he
was considering taking a server job and
leaving the industry entirely so he
decided to give fame and fortune one
last shot safran has said that of all
the actors in the series badgley's real
personality is closest to his character
i'm not taking anything from you blair i
was invited and as for taking me down
i'd love to see you try the idea of
casting blake lively actually came from
checking out forums where fans of the
books were pitching their own ideas
lively had starred in the sisterhood of
the traveling pants and several book
fans were sure she'd make a perfect
serena as it turns out creator schwartz
and savage agreed at the time lively was
also thinking about getting out of
acting and going to college the network
assured her she could make both the show
and attend columbia university at the
same time she didn't get it in writing
in her contract though so it never
actually happened always get it in
writing kids
or better yet just don't go to college
no okay go to college shut up
you shut up
die no
downton abbey of course i'll marry you
you old boobie
i thought you'd never ask
perhaps the british historical drama
downton abbey feels like such an
accurate snapshot of daily life in an
english manor house because it was
created by a bonafide member of
england's landed gentry novelist and
screenwriter julian fellowes who
conceived of the series alongside
british tv producer gareth neem is also
known as baron fellows of west stafford
and sirs is a member on the british
house of lords so remember if you meet
him in person you got a curtsy but do
not hold it for longer than three
seconds fellows had previously written
the oscar-winning screenplay for robert
altman's film gosford park and penned
out the series as a spin-off of that
film however along with neem he
ultimately chose to bump back the action
by several decades downton abbey begins
in 1912 while the action in gosford park
kicks off in 1932
and set the series in an original
location and mary crawley
of course you are
i mean i've been longing to meet you
because i've heard so much about you
from matthew
oh that is nice things i hope
[Music]
what else would you hear from me there's
no real place called downton abbey sorry
to everyone who wanted to go the
exteriors were all shot at high claire
castle in north hampshire along with
many of the interiors the grand foyer
and staircase that are so memorable from
the show that's the real entrance to
high claire some of the house though
have received modern upgrades so anytime
you're seeing bedroom interiors or
servants quarters those were constructed
on sound stages at west london's ealing
studios outdoor scenes to pick the real
village of bampton in oxfordshire high
coir is owned by the earl and countess
of carter vaughn who keep the property
open to the public oh good news we can
go it can even be rented up for weddings
and events to love cherish and to obey
till death as do part downton abbey set
the record for the most emmy nominations
and wins of any international series
wrapping up with 69 nominations and 15
total trophies which if you're keeping
scores 15 more than gossip girl
if you could just wait
it was a boy
however the only actor from the ensemble
to win an emmy for her performance was
dame maggie smith who took home three
supporting actress prizes total for
playing violet crowley the countess
oh do you think i might have a drink
oh i'm so sorry
i thought you were a waiter
i mean that's what they say if you want
to win an oscar you play a real person
but if you want to win an emmy you play
a countess sybil is entitled to her
opinions no
she isn't until she is married then her
husband will tell her what her opinions
are oh granny
shameless you know what
they did it all no thanks to you because
you weren't here and i appreciate that
fiona
that
i'm here now and
liam belongs with me
he doesn't even know who you are i'm his
mother you are my mother too
shameless aired for 11 seasons and 134
total episodes making it showtime's
longest running series in history the
network's first choice for potter
familia's frank gallagher was actor
woody harrelson at a party harrelson
told william h macy who ended up taking
the role that he was a big fan of the uk
version and didn't think he could top
actor david throwfall's performance macy
quipped well i can
what a conniving
nasty little genius
here i thought she was a straight
shooter this requires real craft
i feel deep love for her another fun
casting note about two years prior to
appearing together in shameless emmy
rossum and justin chatwin co-starred in
the much maligned 2009 live-action film
dragon ball evolution she played bulma
and he was goku the film was a notorious
flop and has 15 on the tomato meter but
actually if you go back it uh doesn't
really hold up at all that original uk
version was a kinda autobiographical
series based on the real experiences of
creator paul abbott who's on board the
american remake as an executive producer
both abbott and john wells the west wing
and er vet who developed the american
remake strove to set the show's
characters and world apart from previous
attempts to depict working class or blue
collar americans abbott said
specifically he wanted the characters to
experience a more immediate and even
desperate level of poverty than
comparable shows like my name is earl or
roseanne the first rule you learn in
this house
you hide the
money
wells resisted the network's efforts to
set the show in the deep south or in a
trailer park which he felt would play
too stereotypically and opted instead
for the canaryville neighborhood on the
south side of chicago most of the series
was actually filmed in chicago and the
home used as the gallagher's has become
a popular destination for tourists the
current homeowners have asked people to
not share the address and also request
that anyone coming by to take pictures
leave donations in a basket on the porch
that's probably what the gallaghers
would not do but it's a nice gesture
leave him a tip where should we put him
where he belongs open it up carl got it
scandal
what what's going on what are you doing
deal's off off what's with the pictures
these are for the tabloids smile
tabloids think i'll leak them to the
post first morning shows will pick this
story up in seconds what are you talking
about oh i'm gonna destroy you super
producer shonda rhimes became a
household name after creating the
blockbuster medical drama grey's anatomy
but did you know before that she was a
prominent hollywood screenwriter she
wrote not only the mega sequel the
princess diaries ii royal engagement but
also the britney spears classic
crossroads how do you top that folks
oh right by creating grey's anatomy then
scandal okay got it the concept for
scandal came together after rhymes and
her producing partner betsy beers had a
two-hour meeting in 2009 with judy smith
the pr expert was a former special
assistant to george herbert walker bush
who served as bill clinton's crisis
manager during the monica lewinsky
scandal after chatting with smith rhymes
and beers immediately decided to develop
a tv project based on her life and work
and thus olivia pope was born a bullet
in my head is your only chance at
freedom
good
now all you have to do is pull the
trigger
before carrie washington was brought on
both gabrielle union and tarashi p
henson auditioned to play olivia taraji
p henson later told people she wasn't
sure why she even bothered to try out
because it was obviously perfect for
kerry washington washington became the
first african-american woman to lead a
broadcast network drama series since
teresa graves on get christy love way
back in 1974.
a season 3 episode vermont is for lovers
too was directed by ava duvernay and
became the first tv episode created by a
black woman starring a black woman and
directed by a black woman in network tv
history that is some groundbreaking
television folks i am not a toy you can
play with when you're bored or lonely or
horny i am not the girl the guy gets at
the end of the movie i am not a fantasy
if you want me earn me washington was
nominated for emmys twice for playing
olivia but never got the win she did
eventually collect a trophy in 2020 but
it wasn't for her acting she went for
executive producing the tv special live
in front of a studio audience all in the
family and good times hey it's still a
trophy on your shelf
[Music]
vikings
you know what about you no no
anyone
who
wants to be king
vikings which debuted back in 2013 on
canada's history network was inspired by
stories about legendary norse hero
ragnar lodbrock the subject of a number
of old norse poems in icelandic sagas
hey kind of like thor and loki the
series opens in the year 793 and
re-imagines ragnar as a farmer who rises
to prominence by raiding england
eventually being crowned a scandinavian
king it's rooted specifically in three
works the icelandic saga tale of ragnar
wadbrok the old norse story tale of
ragnar's sons and the 12th century
danish historical chronicle jesta
denorum or deeds of the danes think of
them as medieval fanfiction largely
composed centuries after the events
they're describing do you swear
allegiance and fealty
to me and to my family from this day
forth it won't be so long then
the show was created by michael hurst
who had previously worked on two very
different historical drama series for
showtime the tudors and the borgias
hearst became interested in the viking
era after working on a different script
about 9th century english king alfred
the great who would fund the viking wars
on the other side in his research hearst
found that the viking story was
typically related by their enemies
because the vikings themselves weren't
too big on writing things down so what
we know of their culture and lifestyle
was basically reported by the christian
monks in communities they were attacking
naturally exaggerating their
bloodthirstiness and violence so hearst
was inspired to try and tell a story
from the vikings point of view kind of
like the hague are the horrible comics
but you know a little more detailed and
accurate and in this case live action
[Music]
whenever possible the show made use of
practical effects rather than computer
animation in the season three episode to
the gates when the vikings lay siege to
paris a real 13
800 square foot set was constructed and
filled with hundreds of extras to
recreate the storming of the castle
walls we are going to lift the boats
up the cliff in the season four episode
portage the crew actually used a rope
and pulley system to haul boats over the
side of a cliff as the real vikings
would have done though they also had a
crane attached to the boat to ensure it
wouldn't fall i mean come on vikings you
didn't think of everything
jane the virgin the reason the test came
back positive is
i accidentally inseminated you two weeks
ago
you what the cw's j and the virgin is
loosely based on the venezuelan
telenovela wanna love virgin which ran
for 153 episodes all within the year
2002. that's how they release telenovela
folks and it is intense the cw version
only had 100 episodes but they aired
over five full seasons from 2014 to
2019. we like to pace ourselves i'm the
father
what
baby that you're carrying the cw show
really doesn't have all that much in
common with the original series setting
itself up is more of a parody of the
telenovela format than a recreation
other than the basic setup about a young
woman who gets pregnant after an
artificial insemination mishap jane the
virgin basically goes its own way they
even aged up the character significantly
wanna is only 17 in the venezuelan
series but are jane starts season one at
age 23. i just asked her while i knew
her first oh i know her better i was
married to her a long time ago did you
know that she has a fear of driving
through car washes did you know that she
and i are on the same cycle
gina rodriguez was only the third actor
the creative team met with to play jane
but creator jenny snyder irman felt
right away that she was ideal for the
part intuitively grasping how to
approach the role the show launched her
into a literal overnight success when
she won a golden globe for plain jane in
2015 rodriguez was still living in a
small apartment the night before the big
show the actress slept on her couch so
that her parents in town from puerto
rico could use the bed jane the virgin
never won an emmy during its run though
anthony mendes was twice nominated for
the best narrator award for his sultry
latin lover voice overs you know what
while zoe catches her breath why don't i
catch you up on jane and raff's finances
okay in the last nine weeks jane and
rafael have saved enough money to pay
off the freaking clock so in other words
there
back to square one menez is exclusively
a voice-over artist who has never acted
on camera he said he was originally put
off from the script because it used the
phrase latin lover and he assumed it
would be a tiresome and stereotypical
take once he actually read the script
and realized there was a send-up of the
tropes around telenovelas and latin
lovers he quickly changed his mind
will you marry me
yes
empire and god
please
do not withhold your blessings
even from
that hire to spy on me in jesus name i
pray amen
hallelujah
the music industry crime drama empire
was one of the most watched fox series
throughout its run and an immediate hit
for the network within its first month
on air empire was reaching 12 million
viewers each week according to nielsen
season one of empire posted more
consecutive ratings gains week to week
than any other first year season in more
than two decades the only tv show that
outdoor in the first year was amc's the
walking dead i knew i heard your voice
you evil [ __ ]
co-creators danny strong and lee daniels
came into the project with very
different ideas for what the show would
become strong wrote the pilot and said
he was inspired by great works about
loyalty and succession including
shakespeare's king lear and james
goldman's the lion in winter daniels who
directed the pilot cited the classic abc
primetime sub dynasty as the model he
was aiming for somehow the exact
intersection between these two concepts
was empire i went to jail
[Music]
stars taraji p henson and terence howard
who play hip-hop mogul's cookie and
lucious lion respectively had worked
together several times prior to empire
most notably in the 2005 film hustle and
flow see that was for cookie
see i got a whole lot of memories coming
back to me and unfortunately when that
concerns you they're all bad and it
makes me want to shoot you when you're
down here after reading the script in
2014 it was henson who suggested to
producers that they bring in howard
before that wesley snipes had also been
considered for the role of lucious so
long as he promised to stop trying to
skate uphill it's a
joke from blade and a funny one i never
let anything come between friendship
except the bullet
the show always had full-time musicians
on staff to create the original music
being released by the fictional empire
entertainment for the first two seasons
iconic hip-hop producer timbaland wrote
all the songs for the show in some cases
based on prompts or themes provided by
the writers after timbaland departed in
season three rodney dark child jerkins
and esther dean replaced him once i get
finished whipping both of y'all's asses
[Music]
you're gonna wish you never met a hood
rat like me
just swiping my hands
this is us because all i know is if i
had been there i would have walked
through literal fire and i would have
pulled that man out
hmm
well kev i guess we'll never know
because you weren't there
and he died ashamed of you
i mean you're not even chasing dad's
shadow kevin you're chasing mine but
you'll never be him and you'll never be
me because you'll never know what it's
like to devote yourself to anyone other
than yourself
the nbc drama this is us started life as
an 80 page movie script that creator dan
fogelman wrote while working at abc
studios in 2015. the story followed
eight different adults who were
eventually revealed to be octuplets
after he moved his contract from abc to
20th century fox television bogaman
reworked the octuplet script into a tv
pilot mostly by dropping several
characters the title this is us was the
result of a long brainstorming process
other titles they considered included 36
happy birthday and the story of us
he his life is gonna be challenging
enough he doesn't need to have a dad
who's gonna drop dead one day trying to
teach him how to tie his shoes
oh like his mom might
i didn't say that
because the show plays around with
chronology and time events are planned
out far in advance while most tv dramas
approach each season as essentially a
new story arc by the second season of
this is us bogoman already had a rough
outline for all the major events that
would occur throughout the show's six
season run
most of the events resulting in tissues
this also means that it's crucial to
keep plot details a secret as much of
the show is based on twists and turns
many of which won't be revealed for
multiple seasons
[Music]
[Applause]
when a major character is going to be
killed off script pages were redacted
code names were used and the entire crew
was asked to sign non-disclosure
agreements sequences were also shot in
random order to throw off the paparazzi
this is really like they're making a
star war i want you to stand out
i want all of you
to be as different
as you can possibly be
in all the best ways
jack chevelle on the series is actor
milo with emilia's real car which he
donated to the production in lieu of
payment vent emilia asked the production
to spend the cost of the car on coffee
and burgers for the crew what a nice guy
he could've just bought me a camaro
which again is what i've always wanted
but i like talking to you
a lot
you
make me feel like i'm home
pose god may have blessed you with
barbies a backyard with a pony and a
boyfriend named jake and an unwanted
pregnancy that your father paid to
terminate so you can go to college and
major in being a basic
none of these things make you a woman
clear your throat are you ready to feel
old stephen canales wrote the first
version of the pose pilot while
attending ucla film school in
2014. he was inspired by the classic
documentary about new york's ballroom
culture paris is burning he says he
pitched the concept over 150 times to
various studios and executives before
finally getting yes from uber producer
ryan murphy i can't go in there i'm not
like them
each season of the series is set in a
different era canals explained that the
time jumps allowed the writers to make
the stories more compelling and dynamic
they weren't pinned down by what had
immediately happened to these people
previously but could think long term
about where their path was taking them
1990 was also chosen because it was such
an eventful year for the lgbtq community
and ballroom culture including national
protests over access to hiv treatment
and of course the debut of madonna's
vogue the catholic church has spent
millions of dollars putting the false
message into the world that condoms
don't work and that abstinence is the
only way to fight hiv that is a lie
and that is morally wrong the show was
one of the first in tv history to insist
on trans inclusion both in front of and
behind the camera over 140 trans actors
and crew members worked on pose and gay
and trans people accounted for more than
half of the total cast and crew janet
mock became the first trans woman of
color to work as a writer producer and
director on a tv series while billy
porter became the first openly gay black
man in history to be nominated for and
win lead actor in a drama series in
2019. pose was also nominated for best
drama that very same year well who's
gonna love you like i do huh
nobody you ain't got no education you
ain't got no job no money no home no
skills
and worst of all you are positive that's
why your ass came to me don't nobody
want us so whether you'd like to treat
yourself to just one episode a week as a
little snack or binge through a new show
within the first 48 hours that's a lot
of classic tv to comb through and don't
forget you can find so many more great
dramas that weren't even mentioned here
in rotten tomatoes the ultimate binge
guide book a bingeable bucket list of
all the shows you need to see before you
die coming november with pre-orders open
now as always keep it here on rotten
tomatoes for lots more info about all
the movies and tv shows that matter most
or just matter a lot we don't want to
make it a competition you do you and
i'll see you next time on rt ascension
[Music]
you